[MUSIC PLAYING AND CROWD
CHEERING]
We're joined by the god
of thunder, Chris Hemsworth!
Thank you very much.
It's really fun to get to
be a 6 foot character when
you're a 5' 3" girl, you know?
That doesn't happen
often in your life.
His name is
self-explanatory, isn't it?
It's exciting and humbling.
And I don't know
if they're trying
to usher me out
to the finish line
quickly and get on with it.
But either way, I'll take it.
It's been a lot of bloody fun.
I think everyone was
really having a good time.
And you can tell when you
watch it, like it's a party.
WOMAN: Valkyrie!
Valkyrie!
No, she's just a big
pile of mush, you know?
I think Taika wanted to make
a romantic comedy set in space
and it's that.
I've spent years in
space now at this point,
so it's becoming
really normal to be.
[LAUGHS]
She's into the suits.
She loves musical theater.
Well, well, well,
what's happening, team?
We all right?
Let's give a shout out to all
these wonderful cosplayers
out here, man.
[CROWD CHEERING]
I love it.
Taika Waititi.
Hello, sir.
[CROWD CHANTING]
I didn't ask them to do this.
OK.
This genre is the Taika genre.
I've got to ask you a
little bit more about Taika.
Is he like a big brother?
Is he like a funny uncle?
Is he a tyrant?
What's he like on set?
A bit of all three, I guess.
I love it.
There's zero pressure
on me and there's
all the pressure on Taika.
Taika is just amazing.
He's a force of nature.
[MIMICKING NEW ZEALAND ACCENT]
I've re-written the script,
mate, and you know,
I decided to put
some goats in there and see
what he's going to do with them.
I'm really amazed
with all the actors I
managed to get into this film.
You know, we had to
plan the whole dance
that Taika and I had planned.
We didn't get to shoot it again.
That will be for another film.
But a whole Gorr dance.
You know, sometimes
with villains
you just need them to be
bad and not amazing dancers.
I'm pretty sure
if I say anything,
a Marvel sniper will get me.
I can tell you nothing.
I can tell you Thor is in it.
But you know how Marvel is.
They won't even let us
know what's going on.
And so I'm about to
go in this theater
and find out what
the hell we did.
How does it feel to know
that people are talking more
about your biceps than his?
Well, I mean--
It was all my doing.
I wouldn't ask her that.
No, no.
No, let's just keep
that between us.
OK.
Hats off to anyone who has
to deal with acrylic nails.
I couldn't do anything.
Am I a fully fledged Guardian?
WOMAN: Yes.
Yes, I think I am.
The nice-- oop.
That's OK.
- My apologies.
No, you're all good.
Christian Bale, you can bump
into me any time you want to.
Gorr and the Mighty
Thor in Thor four.
- More!
- More.
Yeah, there is is.
The fans can tell me.
Why is Valkyrie important?
[CROWD CHEERING]
She's a bad ass.
Yeah.
I hope everybody
loves the movie.
Thanks for having me.
This is the best.
I'm so happy to be back.
I feel so lucky to be
back with this crew.
Made this movie for you.
You're the best fan
base in the world.
[CROWD CHEERING]
We love you.
Thank you.
It's just been unlike
anything else I've done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]